on the streets of yerevan on thursday
armenia's prime minister was defiant in
the face of calls from the military for
him to stand down
it's tense but we all agree there should
be no clashes nicole passionian told his
supporters
passionian has been under pressure to
resign after his country lost last
year's war with azerbaijan
over the region of nagorno-karabakh
what is happening now the statement from
the general staff calling for my
resignation
i consider it an attempt at the military
coup you know that i took all
responsibility for what happened and
tried to do everything to answer all the
questions myself
now we have come to a stage where we
cannot avoid questions towards some of
our high level ranking military
personnel
more than three and a half thousand
armenian soldiers were killed in the
six-week conflict
a significant number for a country with
a population
of under three million passion yan was
forced to see large swathes of territory
around nagorno-karabakh
that armenia had controlled for almost
30 years since the end of the last war
with azerbaijan
that prompted weeks of protests led by
the opposition
pashanyan had pushed them from power in
2018 in what was called the velvet
revolution
after an attempt by the previous leader
to stay in control beyond his term limit
the prime minister and this government
have diminished popularity
but the alternative the discredited
political opposition
has much less support so
in general there's little alternative to
pashinyan or his government
but this is unprecedented in terms of
a military threat to the government
much greater and more grave than
anything
the discredited and unpopular political
opposition could mount
what's not clear is whether the army is
willing to use force to back its call
for the prime minister to step down
passing yan says he'll announce a
replacement for the head of the army in
the coming days
the crisis he says will be resolved
constitutionally bernard smith al
jazeera
let's get an update from our producer
garam vardanyan who's joining us on the
phone from yerevan just tell us what
you're seeing around you and what's
happening on the ground garam
hello the pashinya's rally just finished
uh he was only one who was speaking
during this rally and now people are
marching in the
streets of yerevan his supporters
are marching
[Music]
he is leaving the mark uh
with the heavy presence of the police
security guys
but he is leading the march people
[Music]
march is the opposite of the
second square mission as you know
opposition had another rally
in the another square but this
yes rally uh moving not towards the
second square but opposite side of the
square so they are marching
during his speech uh he was saying that
all the together
[Music]
that we will have to show uh
our will to stay at the power because if
they
i was elected uh and you should decide
what will happen with you what can you
tell us about the presence of any
security
uh garam and what is the mood like
amongst the people and those protesters
on the streets right now
um so i i think
two different moves today like
in the world where uh i've seen uh
opposition
uh developing uh resolution of
pakistan's industry
and in the second square right now i can
see people
who are supporting pakistan
we are not want the other to come back
to the power
the previous uh authority uh
so this is the first
rally
[Music]
is you say we do you want
me to start negotiations or consultation
for past elections people are chanting
no we need no
uh elections so possibly
not thinking right now about
election even how much support would you
say
passion yan has right now in the country
i hear very very clearly
i'm asking about the support that the
prime minister has in the country
uh his main support are the people he
like his main support is
[Applause]
in the parliament and he always rely on
the people
and he only supports people
his only support are people in industry
so
i think why he was
doing this rally right now he's doing
this valley to steal
the power of the people and to feel how
much
support he has from the people
what about what the military is doing
right now because we know
that at least 40 high-ranking military
officials have called
for passion yan's resignation garam so
how significant would be the next steps
for the military
uh we are here we have some development
uh we know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we'll leave it there a little
difficult to hear you right now
but thank you so much for that update uh
garam from the right in the center of
yerevan
garam reporting on the prime minister
marching with his supporters and his
protesters in the capital
uh you can see in the live picture right
now on our screen
uh let's uh speak to robin foresee
walker robin is joining us now
from so so rob and i'm not sure if you
you were able to hear what our producer
had to say but certainly the life
picture speaks
for itself and uh the prime minister is
out right now on the streets with his
with his supporters
and and the protesters sounds like it
could be a pretty
tense situation what do you think is
going to happen next
you know giggum was talking then about
the fact that
uh mr pachinyan has been trying well has
has signed the the the dismissal of
the head of the military um but the
problem
he now faces is a constitutional one
because the president
has uh so far not put his signature on
that dismissal
um so directly in uh in in
contradicting mr pacinian which seems as
if
from the political side he is running
out of
allies with the president
uh presumably uh reluctant to go ahead
with his orders
and the military reiterating uh their
decision to re call him to on him to
resign
um and also interestingly enough stating
that their their
letter or their statement was not made
without any with with any out
uh side interference i think that's a
nod to the suggestion that maybe
russia was somehow uh involved or
or may have been putting pressure or
finding a way to
to put pressure on mr pacinian through
their
contacts in the military um so
yes it's a very fragile
uh delicate situation for passion
at the same time we have seen very large
numbers
it appears coming out onto the streets
of the capital to republic square to
show their support for him
and uh and and that means that there is
still a lot
more to play for the question is whether
we will see the military
move uh physically into the capital
mr pacinian has called on on the
military on
on the troops to continue to protect the
borders
and called for calm so a lot to still
can still happen in
in a few short hours uh but
he's always uh resorted to relying on
the public because the armenian people
have shown time and again that they
still support this idea that mr pacinian
brought to them which is that they had
the power to make changes in the country
and those were the changes that they
wanted to see which were important ones
political and economic reforms that that
they were hoping would bring an end
to the corruption and the mismanagement
that we saw in armenia prior
to mr pacquiao coming to power but the
karabakh
war last year has really changed
everything given how disastrous it was
for armenia
the the humiliation the loss of of all
of those
of those territories that they held and
the the huge
human toll the thousands of soldiers the
military
personnel who died in that war more than
three and a half thousand
armenian personnel and all of those
families armenia is a small country and
everyone knows
someone who lost a brother or a husband
in that conflict in that fighting yeah
robin and the prime minister has also
said that
change of power can only happen via
early or regular election
so is that the direction armenia is
heading in how likely is it that those
elections
do take place earlier than anticipated
you know when you listen to his speech
he
was a little uh he sort of
seemed to be dodging the the the issue
by saying
do we want snap elections in the crowd
saying
no but of course to hold snap elections
would be able
for him let's say to firmly establish
that he still has the
popular support of armenian voters and
yet on the other hand
if he were to concede and call for snap
elections that would also be
if you like a shut a sign perhaps as he
sees it of weakness
um so but he says he's open to the idea
and
in that speech he talked about having
political consultations to see
uh whether there was a way forward so it
looks as if given everything that's
happening right now
around him and the military getting
involved i think mr pashanyan will be
certainly perhaps more willing to find a
solution to this crisis
and to maybe give a little bit of ground
okay robin thank you so much for
giving us that update from tibilisi